le député libérale de laviolette à
l'assemblée nationale julie boulet a dû
présenter des excuses c'est d'après midi
pour avoir fait un doigt d'honneur en
direction des banquettes de l'opposition
à l'assemblée nationale alain boulay
avait posé ce geste ne pas avoir été
questionné par le député péquiste
stéphane bergeron sur son témoignage
remarqué devant la commission
charbonneau olic auteur
pour moi la question ils étaient 1
tendancieuses vicieuse et blessantes
alors spontanément j'ai fait ce geste
que je regrette alors je m'excuse auprès
d'eux du député de verchères
c'est non non ça a été une période
difficile pour moi tout simplement
acheté une paire ce fut blessé alors
j'ai fait ça sans aucune mauvaise
volonté sans aucune mauvaise volonté
mais même lui qui est ce que vous pensez
de la balle aux actes et j'ai beaucoup
de collègues qui sont qui sont avec moi
alors des fois les caméras pas ce qu'ils
sont cons mais il faudrait peut-être
aussi aller voir ce qu'ils sont
solidaires et aujourd'hui je me suis
aperçu que j'avais beaucoup de gens qui
étaient solidaires et bien écoutez moi
je vous dis que j'ai reçu un accueil
extraordinaire aujourd'hui d'apporter
mon caucus et la commission en tout
respect pour la commission il va
terminer son rapport et des
recommandations pour vos laissé faire le
travail à la commission l'a écouté parce
qu'elle laissait croire que moi j'avais
beau donner ma version à moi alors dans
la vie on ne le doit pas se souvenir de
quelque chose je pense pas que ce soit
illégale et on parle de financement
légal ici y avait rien qui n'était pas
correcte non plus d'en devancer dans
cette chose-là à l'agencé pour moi
c'était une responsabilité délégués et
j'avais paul souvenir comment naît comme
en ai parlé tout simplement
alors j'ai dit la vérité au cul porte
écoutez je voulais dit tout à l'heure
j'avais des collègues et qui est qui qui
avaient une opinion prend un vélo et
keven opinion puis en malheureusement
les médias ont montré ce qui était
plutôt divergents mais moi aujourd'hui
je vois que j'ai une grande partie du
caucus qui est solidaire qui est avec
moi et je suis très heureuse d'être de
retour très très long moment
oui tout à fait tout à fait bah écoutez
moi je connais monsieur bergeron il
était mon critiques pendant jette aux
transports je connais le personnage
connaît sa personnalité alors ça ne m'a
pas étonné tout simplement merci
beaucoup au revoir